Please give a warm welcome TO MATTHEW
DICKS.
>> [applause]
>> IT'S 1991 and I'm 20 years old and I'm
driving home from the very first booty
call of my entire life and I am excited
because I don't know that this is going
to also be the very last booty call of
my entire life.
And then it's in that moment of
excitement that the right front tire of
my 1976 Chevy Malibu blows out, but it
doesn't deflate, it disintegrates. It
throws rubber rubber on the road in a
way that I didn't think was possible and
it takes everything I can to get the car
over to the shoulder and to a stop. And
it's 1991,
I don't have a cell phone. So, I do the
only thing I can, I start hiking up the
road to look for help.
7 hours later
after giving all of my money to a
half-naked mountain man named Winston, I
have a bald tire on my car and I'm
heading home when I look at the
instrument panel and I see that I have
no gas and all of the money that I have
is in Winston's hand. And it's 1991, I
don't have a credit card, I don't have
an ATM card, I don't even have a
checking account.
And so, I take the next exit and I roll
my car into a Getty station.
>> [snorts]
>> And as I park the car, I'm angry and I'm
sad. I'm 20 years old. I'm a McDonald's
manager. I make $7.25
an hour and I'm the richest person I
know.
My mother is living on welfare with my
sister.
My father's left 10 years ago and the
only friend that I have who even has a
credit card or a car that can make this
100-mile trip to New Hampshire is off on
some college weekend and I can't get in
touch with him. And this was not the
plan for my life. I was not supposed to
be this alone.
And so, I go into the Getty station to
beg for gas. $8 worth of gas is all I
need cuz it's 1991 and gas is 85 cents a
gallon.
And the kid behind the counter will not
give it to me. He doesn't want to lose
his job and I offer everything and he
says no. So, I go back to my car, my
plan is to wait for the next shift
change, maybe someone more sympathetic
will take over. But as I climb into my
car, I see my McDonald's uniform
crumpled in the back and I have an idea.
An hour later, I'm in a residential
neighborhood about a mile from the Getty
station. I'm on the porch of a red brick
house and I'm knocking on the door. I'm
wearing my McDonald's uniform, the blue
shirt, the blue pants, the blue tie.
The door opens and there's a man
standing in front of me and I know at
that moment that this is a bad idea.
But it's 3:00 on a Sunday afternoon and
I'm on his porch in a McDonald's uniform
and the only way to get off is to go
forward. So, I say to him,
"My name is Matt. I'm collecting money
for the Ronald McDonald Children's
Charities.
Can you please make a donation?"
And this man stares at me like
Stonehenge. He does not move. He's 50,
but he might as well be 500. He has all
of the wisdom and knowledge of the world
wrapped into one man and I know he knows
I'm lying. And the next words that come
out of my mouth, I don't expect. I say,
"My mom died of cancer when I was young
>> [laughter]
>> and my sister has cancer now and I'm
just trying to do what I can to help."
And he looks at me and points and says,
"You stay right there." And he goes back
into the house and closes the door and I
know that he's calling the police and
I'm going to get arrested for stealing
money from McDonald's, which ironically
2 years later will actually happen.
But not on this day
because he comes back to the door and he
has $20 in his hand, which is like
$20,000 to me on this day and he presses
it into my palm and I say, "No, that's
too much." And he says to me, "My wife
died of cancer 5 years ago."
And I think this is a really bad idea I
had and before I know it, I am sitting
on the porch with this man and he asks
me about my mother died of and I say
breast cancer cuz it's the first one
that pops to my mind. And he says, "What
does your sister have?" And I say
leukemia, which I don't actually know is
a cancer, but I know kids get it. And he
tells me that his wife Lisa died of lung
cancer and that his kids live on the
West Coast. And he tells me how she
struggled for 2 years and how he wanted
to tell her it was okay to go, but he
couldn't and how badly he felt that he
watched her struggle for so long. And I
sat on that porch and I listened to him
and I prayed he wouldn't ask me anything
and I just wanted to get off.
>> [snorts]
>> And so, finally we were hugging and I
was walking down the walk with $20 in my
hand and it felt like poison.
I got to my car and I sat in there and I
remembered how lonely I felt
and then I felt so stupid and small
cuz I knew at that moment I didn't
understand real loneliness. I was a
20-year-old kid with friends and I was
stuck in New Hampshire.
But I had walked away from a man who was
in a tiny house with a wife that was
gone and the kids that were gone and he
had a loneliness in him that I would
never understand.
And so, I put the gas in my car and I
drove home.
But he has always been with me.
I have never left that man on that porch
that day
and I'm hopeful that I'll never be as
lonely as he was that day. Thank you.
>> [snorts]
[applause]